[ typing ]
>>We start with immersion,
where we dive in and begin
to become exposed to the
realities of what we're trying
to pursue, and these other...
>>Narrator: English teacher Susan
is explaining a learning expedition
to parents who are considering
enrolling their students
at Casco Bay High School.
>>Susan: Then building background
knowledge in social studies class,
they looked at the Great Depression
and tried to unearth what happened
in that economic crisis
and how can we compare...
>>Narrator: The project McCray
and her students are diving
into explores the realities
and impact of homelessness
in their hometown of Portland, Maine.
>>Susan: Then investigation comes,
and that's when we started
these documentary projects,
where we went out and had
the opportunity to talk
to people who've experienced
homelessness.
>>Susan: The work that we do that we
believe in, it has to be compelling
and it has to be looking at the real
world, so we designed this expedition
to act as a case study
of one policy issue.
Policy is compelling
because it is about need,
but it can become very academic,
and I think what we can lose
is the notion of human story
and how these issues impact
and affect real lives.
>>Okay, how long have
you each been homeless?
>>I've been in and
out of the shelters on
and off, like, 22 years, and...
>>Susan: So, what this project
has done is allowed us to look
at the historic piece, while
at the same time looking
at the contemporary
economic crisis and then
to really make a link
with a human being.
>>So, how did that affect you?
>>Because of the way you
have to live and the fact
that you may not be proud of it.
Wears on your self-esteem, no
matter how good your self-esteem is.
It's going to be --
it's very draining.
>>Emma: Even knowing that there's
a large homeless population
in Portland, like, it's something you
know, but actually being able to talk
to people about it is -- it's
something really different,
and that's what I really like
about expeditions like this.
You get to really know it
rather than just look at it
and be like, "Oh, that's nice."
Like, you're immersed, so...
>>You know the drill idea.
Keep that a little bit higher up.
>>Hold on a second.
>>Narrator: During the
eight-week project,
students will write their own
individual profiles and contribute
to a group multimedia presentation.
>>Should I redo that?
>>Yeah. We already -- we can't...
>>Susan: I mean, it's incredible
what we're able to do so simply.
We just click on GarageBand
and it goes.
Everybody's got a cell phone
that can take a picture,
and everybody can load the
image onto the computer
in the classroom instantly, and
with my LCD projector, boom,
we're looking at people's work.
>>We talked to Alden in the
back room of Down-Home Cookin',
a small coffee shop on Preble Street.
>>Susan: I think it's easy for
people sometimes to think, "Oh, well,
this multimedia is kind
of gimmicky," right?
"It's just for the
sake of the polish.
Where's the learning in it?"
>>...told us he had been homeless on
and off for three or four years now.
>>Susan: Well, I try peer
critique all the time.
I'm still trying to
work on how am I going
to make peer critique
happen more effectively
when we work on our writing?
And in this project they've each
written their personal pieces,
and then I've asked them to
each take a piece of that
in their team to produce one story.
Well, the process that went on
there, I mean, kids were riveted,
and here's this authentic reason:
"I think we should use your opening,
because your -- I really liked
your description of the setting
and what was going --
and the character there,"
and that's high-level thinking
and crafting of narrative.
They're critiquing.
>>So I think that was really
working was their slides.
I don't know how to
explain it, but it just kind
of meshed, like with their words.
>>People lose hope out
there, paver-marked,
talk about why homeless
people stay homeless.
They get stuck and feel
like there's no way out.
>>Narrator: On this night, McCray's
students read the profiles they've
written to this group of parents.
Days later, at a local art gallery,
they will present their multimedia
products to their primary audience:
the subjects of their work.
>>We walked up three
flights of stairs
in the Oxford Street shelter
past 154 6-inch-thick mats.
The shelter...
>>Susan: The process is
driven by culmination,
because we all get involved when we
know that we have a real audience,
and our real audience
is our community
but most significantly
the people we interviewed.
What could matter more than making
sure the story is right for them?
>>Andrew is 46 years old.
There was nothing about
Andrew that stood out.
>> For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org